[音楽]
キャップボックス
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですはい皆
さんポケモンカード書いてますか9月の
22日発売ポケカの最新弾レイジング
サーフが発売されましたおめでとうござい
ます私今回も
頑張らせていただきましたなんと
メイジングサーフ100ボックス入手し
ました
嘘です100ボックスなんて買えません
そもそも手に入らないんですけれども前回
も黒縁の支配者というポケカのボックス出
た時に100ボックス開封したんです
けれども今回も同様にこちらのレイジング
サーフ100ボックス僕のではありません
僕のじゃありません
欲しいです欲しいんですけれども100
ボックスなんてとても1人じゃ買えないの
で僕と99人のポケカプレイヤーに集まっ
ていただいて一人一ボックスずつ持ってき
てこちらに100ボックス
準備しましたで今から100ボックス
みんなで開封しますはいこれね1ボックス
しか開けれないんですけれどもみんなで
開けることによってまるで100ボックス
開けたかのような感覚になれるという
めちゃくちゃ幸せ企画のレイジングサーフ
バージョンですポケカにはですねこの
ボックスの中にSRって言われている
すごいいい光り方してるカードが1枚入っ
てるんですけれどもそれのなんか割合と
いうか確率とかもわかると思いますで中に
はひょっとしたら2枚入っているボックス
のあるかもしれないのですちょっと何
ボックス出るかも楽しみですね色んなこと
がわかるのでぜひ皆さんこの動画を見て
100ボックス開けた感覚になって
くださいでは行きましょう
[音楽]
それではレイ
ジングさ100ハグかよ
それではレイジングサーフ100ハブ開封
始め
[音楽]
一発目
最初から出るみたいなことはやめたい
[拍手]
[音楽]
待って待って初手多いなさて
初手
[音楽]
いませんでしたSR出たもの
結構いるね
7人7人
[音楽]
ちょっと見ていきましょうか
を記念すべき第1号です
[音楽]
当たりじゃない当たりです
行きます
[拍手]
個人的に欲しいんだよね
[音楽]
お願いします
何が出るかな
[音楽]
[拍手]
危ないもう出たよ
[音楽]
もう出たんだけどすごいねスクール
だね
[音楽]
[拍手]
なんか子供に優しい世界だね
かっこよ
[音楽]
でも使ってね
6人開けて3分x3枚出てます
[音楽]
トップレア3枚とサーフ5
このビッグウェーブに
乗りたい
[音楽]
さあ
教えてくれ
1名かな
[音楽]
お願いします
欲しかったな
[音楽]
パラソルお姉さん
雪山のコイX
良かった
ちょっと今日は早めに俺は出したい
もう出てくれないかな
おす
すごいすごいすごい
めっちゃ出る
[音楽]
[拍手]
カップコケコEXSR
お願いします
[音楽]
クーパーUXSR
[拍手]
おおチリちゃん
お願いします
[音楽]
[拍手]
お年取り
[音楽]
めっちゃ出てますねなんか前回と比べて
めっちゃ出てますトップレアウェーブ23
回しかする予定なかったんだけど
[音楽]
お願いします
青木SR
[拍手]
[音楽]
青木さん
こうやってきた波が今は
6発目
[音楽]
僕最後に見ます
すいません間違えました
[音楽]
嬉しくないかっこいい
やつ普通に嬉しいけどな
[音楽]
[笑い]
はい
[音楽]
SR指揮者
リバーサルエネルギーUR
[音楽]
ussy
9番目
出ればいいんですけどね
[音楽]
おめでとうございます
今何枚出てるんだ早くもパラソルを
お姉さんのSR2枚出てますもうみんな
このビッグウェーブに乗るしか
10発目
[音楽]
[拍手]
カーソルお姉さん
11発目
仕切り
スーパーXS
[拍手]
R
[音楽]
[拍手]
OK
[音楽]
です
まだ2枚箱出たものはいないか
まだいないか
ないみたいなパターンの可能性もあります
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
みんな15パック開けました折り返しだお
疲れ様です
[音楽]
前回ははるかに上回るSARの当たり確率
大変待機であるお見事だ
[音楽]
ただまだ
1枚だけ出てないSR枠がある
当ててくれ16発目
します
[拍手]
か
[音楽]
パラソルお願いします
CDS
[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さん全種類入れました
ここからはいかに
可愛いカードを出すから
頑張っていいからたくさん出しましょう
17パック
の方前にお願いします
4名の2枚箱を記念して超高速
お願いします
[音楽]
サーフ5XSR
今まだ1枚の人がいる
[音楽]
月見草
2枚は着きました
[拍手]
[音楽]
お願いしますSR
22パック目
オス
2枚箱を祝福しまして102秒
そうです
[音楽]
23発目
二枚箱がいいな
[音楽]
ガブリリアスXX
[拍手]
それ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ジュニアさん
27パック目
2枚箱
2枚は拘束しまして
001秒それ
ほいで
[拍手]
カーソルお姉さんこの子2枚出してます
[音楽]
[拍手]
いや困ったね
[音楽]
ちょっと青木が増えてきたぞー
XSR
5XS
[音楽]
久々に見たな
ラスト1パックだまだ1枚も出ていない人
はいるか
[音楽]
君たちは確定でSRが入っているはずだ前
に来てくれないか
確定者を除いて他のみんなで開けましょう
30パック目
ありがとうございました2枚はこの人はい
ますか
届けたいと思うお願いします
[音楽]
最後だみんな
押す
[拍手]
[音楽]
皆さんお疲れ様でした
100ボックスを開けた結果お知らせ
いたしますキックボックス中2枚箱だった
箱が8ボックスありましたありがとう
ございます
SR枠の枚数何枚出たか発表しますHR
から発表しますお年寄りEXが6枚
雪目残りxが6枚スーパーEXが7枚
サーフボeX9枚カプコケコEX8枚
ガブリアスEX6枚青木9枚仕組み11枚
チリちゃん7枚パラソルお姉さんがなんと
11枚出ました
カーソルお姉さんめっちゃ出てましたね
続いてURですあの黄色のやつビーチ
コートが3枚リバーサルエネルギーが1枚
ガブリアスEXが5枚でした
[拍手]
エネルギー出にくいんですかねすごいレア
な気がします続いてスペシャルアートレア
ですサーフボーEX4枚カプコケコEXが
4枚ガブリエスEXが3枚チリちゃん3枚
パラソルお姉さんが5枚でした
なんかすごい序盤めっちゃ出て
盛り上がりすぎて後半どうしようって感じ
だったんですけどもすごい楽しかったです
ありがとうございました
次は
未来と古代でお会いしましょうありがとう
ございました